25 years ago today Point Break was
released one of the stars Lori petti you
can see her now is orange is the new
black she was Tyler in Point Break and
kind enough to join us on short notice
did you know this was the anniversary
there Laurie no not till you've sent me
the email this morning I got up like I
heard my phone ding at like 6 o'clock
and it said oh it's a 25th anniversary
call us it's like okay what do you
remember about that when you got the
script oh I just had a blast I was just
so happy I was so so thankful you know
it was like my first big movie and I
just done one movie before that Cadillac
man and then I did Point Break and just
just the artistry of Kathryn Bigelow you
know she's a painter she's you know
she's an amazing director she she's a
photographer she's you know and she's
fearless so that was super fun did you
have to audition oh yeah I did some
probably five times but I got to read
with Keanu a bunch of times and we
became friends you know right away and
yeah it's just super super happy then we
get to Hawaii and they take me into this
like my room which is huge beautiful
amazing suite with columns and billowing
great breezes you know all this right on
the ocean and I called downstairs and I
said I think I'm in the wrong room for
like what do you mean I'm like well
where's the Queen gonna stay cuz I
Palace yeah I was just so much fun now
we did some research and we were told
that Charlie Sheen was originally going
to be in that movie instead of Canada I
miss either missed that or forgot that
cuz I don't remember that interview I
just remembered Keanu what do you
remember about Patrick Swayze oh he was
just the sweetest thing in the world he
just he's a super hard worker like you
said I heard you earlier um when I was
listening on the phone he would get up
in the morning and go skydiving and do
his ballet he does ballet in the sky
this guy right
or he would like go surfing or go
running you know before before we went
to work and just a sweetheart my sister
worked with me on the film and we were
taking press photos one day and Lisa
said I can't take a picture with Patrick
either I said shirt right he's so sweet
you can so they take a picture lisa has
it on her desk at work and people think
it's a cutout from Hollywood because
he's so perfect
Loie and golden you know they think like
oh how cute you got a picture with a
cutout did you know how to surf
oh no but I learned because I mean I've
been an athlete my whole life and I
skateboarded and you know we all we we
trained for like two months maybe
but you only more but then okay what was
tougher though trying to surf or
baseball when you play a hit in league
of their own
perfect means way harder surfing's way
harder yeah baseball I played since I
was a little kid so that was easy
was super easy what happens when Point
Break comes on like dude stop watch
you can't oh yeah I mean yeah oh yeah of
course I care it's so beautiful I just
thought the Academy did something and
showed it you know outdoors it was all
fancy and I hadn't seen you know the
whole movie and you know ten years or
something and I'm watching it going well
no wonder people like this we're
gorgeous 25 come on give me a break here
it's like the best looking cast in the
world we're talking to Lori petti a 25th
anniversary of Point Break it's on right
now it's it's what it's like Shawshank
it's on time yeah absolutely
oh no I'll stop for a second and watch
it for a second thank you God do you get
residuals from it every time it's played
probably about 46 it's gonna add up
though after 25 years Lori I don't know
I don't think so I mean it's really been
a long time did Jen did you know that it
was going to be a had any success or
that it was going to be anything
more than okay here's a movie and I'll
do another movie after this no no I mean
you you never know but then once I hit
my little stride with how'd it go Point
Break leg of their own
Tank Girl Free Willy I'm like okay I can
make iconic movies that's not bad
what do they ask you about when they
they bring up that topic or that topic
is brought up what do you mean it Point
Break it when somebody know that you're
in it oh my goodness well I live it I
live in Venice Beach so I mean every day
you know I go downstairs to get some tea
you know there's like you know five
teenagers losing their minds so yeah no
there's no and they weren't even born
yet
right yeah they're out there surfing and
it's just it's fantastic I'm glad that
you know that it has legs like that yeah
and now orange is the new black so the
career keeps on hitting high notes here
Oh orange is the new black is like you
know I'm getting Bieber eyes over here I
just had no idea I just I really had no
idea and when I first started the show
and I'd say the like Laura pre-plan I'm
like hey you want to you know grab a
bite after work she goes oh I can't do
that
I know why she goes you don't you'll
find out it's like you know you go home
and order food you don't can't go
outside so it's like boyband crazy yeah
yeah I mean it's great you know I'm
happy that people love the show and I'm
you know like I say to people when
people see me they smile how bad is that
I mean it's not like they're looking at
me and being mad you know so I'm you
know I'm always I always take a selfie
with you you know I always talk to your
mom on the phone or whatever because I'm
just thankful it's wonderful we we had
Ken Owen this is two years ago and he
came in and I think he was 50 at the
time but he looked like he was 30 and he
no entourage no nothing he just walked
in he had a suit on and he couldn't have
been nicer he's one of my
top five guests we've ever had just
because there was no air about him he
had fun with it
but that dude is 50 looked like he was
he looked on I don't know what he's done
with the devil but man did he look good
you know
yeah he's and as you know what I mean
his heart's just as good as you know
what I mean so I really think it's from
the inside out you know it's just he's
just a sweetie pie if you ever ask him
for anything there's never a no you know
he's just a just a good good person
my guys want to know this Laurie did
Tyler is Special Agent Utah get married
uh absolutely
and then here's what I think then I
think they had like two kids and now
those two kids are like surfing the
world like a boy and a girl sounds like
there's a movie there Laurie well I am a
writer well you you and can arou and
then you have your two your two kids and
they're surfing the world yeah and then
Bodhi has a kid and nobody knows about
it
Oh awesome and then my daughter falls in
love with him BAM we're gonna get all
the money now yeah yeah we'll get
Bigelow Bigelow will direct it for us
she might be too expensive hey thank you
thank you for getting up early and good
luck with uh oranges new black thanks
for having fun with us thank you so much
and thanks for thanks for reaching out
you have a great day babe all right
that's Laurie penny the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience